you guys look so fantastic i just you
know
the crew when they hoop and holler and
you guys i know it just i can't tell you
i hope that you feel it too
because it really does just warm my
heart to no
end and as we feel so isolated in 2020
it's like a warm blanket that just feels
so good which is exactly why we're doing
cake week
because what is more fitting than
manjamanja with a bunch of flour and
sugar
and as we celebrate throughout the week
we thought we would sprinkle in
a little cake decorate decorating
competition
and we're calling it the ultimate frost
off
that's right and here from columbus
ohio hello columbus ohio
please welcome joanna and her daughter
to kia from jay's sweet treats and
wedding cakes hello ladies
aren't you um all right who's the mom
and who's the daughter i'm not even
joking
you guys look the same age and i'm done
okay i'll take your word for it you're
both
so youthful and beautiful my goodness
mothers it's true me now
[Laughter]
i love mothers and daughters it's my
entire universe and my karma jeremy
journey here on life so how did you get
into business with your daughter
well actually i was just baking for
family and friends it was a hobby
and one of my friends asked me to create
a two-tier cake for her birthday and so
i said okay
having never done it before i am
fearless
um and it came out awesome and the next
thing you know the whole town was asking
us to
bake cakes and so my daughter and i put
together a pop-up shop
and we refer to that as the pop-up shop
that keeps on giving because we've never
stopped
so we started out of our home and we
outgrew that
my husband basically said enough is
enough when he asked what's for dinner
and i say cake cupcakes and cake pops
he wasn't excited about it so uh he
asked what we were going to do so we uh
moved into a brick and mortar
my daughter was helping me out part-time
and he recently came on full-time to be
my right hand
i love it and i know that 2020 has been
such a difficult year
what are your hopes for 2021 may i ask
well first of all we would like covet 19
to go away
it really has put a damper on our foot
traffic
the way that people celebrate a lot of
our large weddings were cancelled
so it really has affected the bottom
line for 2021 we're hoping to just get
back to where we started
and that's a booming business with lots
of custom cakes and a lot of
traffic well i wish that for you and i
do
believe that we are on the verge of
a new year and a new hope and
for today let's take all of that get rid
of it
and have a competition all right let's
see who takes the cake
when it comes to decorating i'm
challenging you both to decorate your
own cakes
with one of my favorite things flowers
lovers
all right are you ready to go all right
let's do this
all right we're gonna check in with you
all so long and by the end we just might
have a little prize for the winner
joanna takia ready set first
okay thank you beautiful ladies before
we dive into our next guest i want to
check in on our frost off competition
joanna
takiyah how's it going it's going good
going good oh i like you when i see
e all right we're going to keep checking
in with you
gorgeous gorgeous ladies all throughout
the show
brb here we go welcome back we got 30
seconds
who's gonna be the winner whoever it is
gets a thousand dollars let's look
oh my gosh those are both so gorgeous
oh who am i gonna pick god this is too
hard
oh god i really love all those flowers
and i love that cake you know what a
thousand dollars for both of you i love
you thank you so much
you're both winners thank you to kian
jawanna and to everyone
watching at home